it's been a while but valuetainment see
that logo right there is officially back
so this is pretty exciting because the
last time we created content was
december 6th of 2021 which means it's
been over nearly six months by the we
haven't created content a lot's happened
since then till today we bought a couple
buildings we moved south from boca to
fort lauderdale this building here was a
bank building and it was a top design in
fort lauderdale but we took it over
there's a vault i'm gonna show you here
in a minute where the pbd podcast being
hosted at uh we got a lot of exciting
things that's coming up new podcast
that's being launched new talent that
you'll hear about a couple of the
talents that we're signing we're pretty
excited about one of them had a show
on the view before she was one of the
co-hosts on the view for over a year
then she went on red eyed and she was on
fox and now she's with us jetta diabeela
we're very very excited about our
podcast that's being launched a few
others we have a new high society show
that we'll be launching which uh you
know you're gonna see yachts and cars
and lifestyle and a little bit of that
and on top of that monday morning we go
back to motivation mondays
tuesdays we go back to business how to's
we have a bunch of original series that
we're working on uh we're recruiting
talent spanish speaking and english if
you're somebody that's a talent with a
good size following you want to find a
home to start a podcast or a show with
recruiting talent english and spanish
speaking let us know but aside from that
we're very excited this break was
definitely needed it's the second time i
think this is the third time we took a
break uh but this time around we got so
many new things to launch and introduce
to you a new app that we're about to
launch
valuetainment.com with a bunch of
different things let's just say if you
wanted to go find a ward that i've ever
used on any of the episodes you click
search and it takes you to any video
that i've ever used that word but
anyways just happy to be back we've been
doing a podcast nothing really going on
with valuetainment but now tim is also
back lots of surprises coming soon but
i've missed you have you missed me i've
been thinking about you a lot i feel
like we've haven't spent enough time
together we're going to start doing that
again take care everybody see you soon
bye
[Music]
you